do you think that private corporations
have more information on the phenomenon
than the government I don't know about
more but I think some of the aerospace
companies who are contracted with the
government probably have a lot of have
information they've been looking into
some of these the physical materials and
physical evidence for this
and I'm not in a position to know how
much of that is shared with the
government and whether they if they keep
a lot of it to themselves
can you expand on how some private
aerospace companies may have material
how do they come in possession of that
what do they do with it
well I wish I knew more um again this is
all super sensitive stuff so I don't
know that much about it but I mean I
I've been told by sources that
aerospace companies definitely are
involved and Harry Reid certainly
strongly implied this in my one
interview I did with him
um and uh others have told me this too
um and you know but how it happens and
what they know and all of those details
I don't know that's all I forget what
your exact question was um
I just I just believe and again another
thing is the Wilson memo that famous uh
Mo written by Eric Davis references
aerospace companies being involved too
you can find it throughout
you know and I'm sure
invest you know researchers who document
all this stuff to the like people like
Richard Dolan and others probably have a
lot of information they probably have it
all organized in terms of every time
it's been referenced you know but um
some of it I noticed from people talking
to sources off the Record who have have
knowledge of this but I don't I don't
know any specifics because it's all
highly sensitive stuff